hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
heilpan show so today is going to be a
great video because Andrew and his
brother Tristan Tate have finally been
released from house arrest I cannot
believe how long they've been locked up
for I think it's 10 months altogether
three months in jail seven months on
house arrest absolutely crazy and a lot
of you guys will be messaging me asking
me my opinion so I'm gonna give you my
opinion in this video and I'm also going
to react to two videos of Andrew the
first one is a press release that he
gave this morning and another one is
from his house but before I get into the
video please don't forget to hit the
like button and subscribe so you stay up
to date on everything that's going on
okay so the first video is a sky news
clip so let's watch it in January when I
was thrown into jail cell the media
reported and told the robot I was a
terrible person they said that I hurt
people and I make a lot of money from
Criminal Enterprise and here we stand
seven or eight months later on the news
I've seen lots of girls sticking up for
me lots of people defending me I'm not
single person stand up and say that I
have hurt them not one
very exhausting to continue to prepare
great lives it's very hard to keep lives
afloat when you have no actual evidence
we've been completely innocent since the
beginning of this and I have to give
absolute Faith to the Romanian judicial
system for finally making the right
decision and letting us free I'm sure in
the end will be absolutely exonerated
and everybody who was pushing these lies
and Reporting things on repeat without
any substantial evidence are going to
have to analyze within themselves why
they decide to try and Destroy people's
lives purely for views I've done nothing
wrong God knows I've done nothing wrong
in my heart I know I've done nothing
wrong I think the people at home who the
functioning brain understand we've done
nothing wrong because nobody has yet to
identify a single victim which is done
which is saying that we've done anything
to them
I'll just pause it there I think Andrew
seems extremely calm extremely collected
I'm quite impressed because I think if
it was anybody else you'd be extremely
angry I really like how respectful he is
of Romania and the country and the
judicial system there I think most
people would be screaming and shouting
at the judges so he's clearly you know
got a lot of patience and respect for
the system maybe this is a strategic
move because I guess when you want the
system to be good to you then you know
you don't really want to be throwing
them under the bus just yet but you know
it's really good to see as well that you
know he's got a lot of trust in himself
um he's still got a lot of trust in God
and I can see that he believes that the
truth will prevail
since the beginning of this entire
process once again absolute respect to
the judge respect to Romania respect to
the remaining judicial system I look
forward to being completely exonerated
in the time thank you what I think is
really interesting as well about this
video is his conviction in himself if
somebody were guilty I think they'd look
kind of like Shifty and Shady but he
knows that he hasn't done anything wrong
and seems extremely convicted that the
truth will prevail and that he will be
exonerated as he says and everything
will work out fine in the end but there
is another video that I'm gonna watch
now and I think this one's a little bit
different I haven't actually watched it
yet so I'm watching it for the first
time with you guys but I've been told
that in this video it's a little bit of
a different Android I think he's as a
professional or well not professional I
don't think he's as at peace I think
he's a little angrier I spent three
months in a jail cell in a dungeon where
cockroaches sharing my blanket with me
three months then I finally got released
seven months I've been locked in my
house so today a judge decided to let me
go I want everybody at home to
understand exactly why that is up until
now all of the imprisonment and the
deprivation of my Liberty had nothing to
do with evidence it wasn't about
evidence in a case File it was the
Romanian tradition the judges have
obviously let them out because of a lack
of evidence how do you lock somebody up
for 10 months or keep them on house
arrest for seven months they're just not
be enough evidence in the cases like
slowly falling through and crumbling it
was the Romanian Judicial System trying
to decide if one I am a public danger or
two I am a Flight Risk and to be fair to
them I am not emotional I am a
professional even when I am suffering
and I understand as an international Man
of huge financial resource it's easy to
deem me a Flight Risk so my Liberty was
deprived only recently I was charged
this indictment appeared I want
everybody at home to also understand
that three different federal agencies
from three different countries have
investigated my life for the last 15
months every photo I've ever taken every
video I've ever made every conversation
I've ever had every phone call 2 000
people who know me were contacted ever
every single ex-girlfriend my vet my
pool guy my old house cleaner an
apartment I used to have 11 years ago
you name them if they had anything to do
with me no matter how teeny is the link
they were contacted and they were
interviewed hotlines were set up
Billboards remain has Andrew K ever hurt
you do you have any information on
Andrew Tate the media was offering 50
000 pounds for anybody who would give a
negative story to me find another man
who has hundreds of ex-girlfriends and
not a single one of them rolled on me
not a single one of them for money would
say I'm a bad person in fact they would
all say the opposite and defend me and
stick up for me you don't talk about a
man of moral fiber find another man who
can go through that there's not another
man on the street you can find his
ex-girlfriends who wouldn't turn on him
the media all over the news annotates
the worst man that's ever been Andrew
takes a human trafficker and it's a
Crime Boss he's a crime Lord entertain
has all this money from Alyssa
activities every penny I've ever made
all of my bank accounts seized 15
million euros of assets were taken from
me they've been through every single
bank transfer that I've ever sent all of
it head to toe to put this indictment
together so when this indictment is
finally created it should be an Opera
right it should be Shakespeare it shoots
so money transfers victims old victims
from long ago videos pictures medical
records this indictment should be
absolutely Bulletproof the indictment
was put together I was held for six
months without charge that's the longest
possible time I can be held without
charge the day before they finally
submitted this indictment it took as
much time as they could they took it
down to the wire every minute they could
to get this indictment together I think
this is Andrew's genuine opinion
Andrew's genuine anger finally coming
out but it's interesting because he will
only post this under his own Andrew
can't show this level of frustration
with the system when he does these press
interviews with Sky News uh the BBC the
guardian whatever it is because you can
imagine that they're going to twist it
Andrew screams at reporters Andrew gets
aggressive with reporters so it's pretty
interesting that now we have this
opportunity to see how he genuinely
feels about the situation and yeah he's
clearly extremely annoyed as would
anybody be and I think he makes a really
interesting point that it has been a 15
a 15-month investigation they've gone
through every little aspect of his life
and nothing to me I I find that so
fascinating and now you don't put in
front of a judge and what does the judge
do the judge has picked up this
indictment looked at it
and said
this is garbage let him go
they're bulletproof indictment after all
I just described they finally put
together a document that the judges
instantly said let him go this man
should not be held
anybody who believes this garbage
anybody who was insulting me while I sat
inside of a jail cell saying that maybe
I am a human trafficker because of some
stupid video from 10 years ago any of
these people who want some salt in me or
refuse to defend me because they were
scared and that's the same thing
something I haven't realized a whole
bunch of people who are my friends now
and on my team now and are now begging
me to bring views to their [__] podcast
didn't have very much to say while I was
sitting in the [__] jail cell that is
so true and I saw actually Andrew tweet
about this it's such a good point
because before Angie went in jail he did
a round of podcast interviews everybody
saw them he was blowing up and he gave a
lot of people even small creators so
much time which obviously blew up their
Channel but then I noticed that a lot of
these same creators who he gave his time
to weren't there to defend him during
his time in jail a lot of people myself
included were there on Twitter spaces
arguing with crazy people talking about
you know talking about morality versus
is what he did actually illegal school
perhaps it's a little unethical but is
it illegal you know where they're having
these debates yet many creators who he
gave so much time to just threw him
under the bus so and I think I'm not
gonna name any names but everybody knows
who those creators are
not very much at all don't think I don't
know me and my team know exactly who was
on my team and who wasn't I also know
what I have done and what I have not
done and God knows the same it doesn't
matter if I get [__] at the end of
this it doesn't matter if I get
completely destroyed no matter what I'm
in jail for life I know what I have done
and I know what I have not done and I
find absolute solace in that now I am
free yes I will remain free until the
trial date when this garbage is finally
thrown out my name is absolutely not
really clear anybody who believed any of
this garbage is going to regret it
because I tell you something Tristan
said something to me in that jail cell
was completely true
he said 13 years in the Chateau deep and
then The World Is Ours if you have not
read The Count of Monte Cristo I
strongly recommend that you do
in my final Act of defiance
against the Matrix I've decided for my
first day of freedom I will visit the
mosque and I will pray to God because
Allah is the best of planners and then I
will return to my house and stay home
that's right you locked me up for 10
months where are you gonna go what are
you gonna do I'm a bit tired I'm gonna
stay in my house I mean it's funny
because like he has a beautiful home so
there's probably no nicer place in
Romania than his home like he has so
much there pools cars amazing you know
he's got a gym like he doesn't really
need to go anywhere other than a mosque
I only want to talk to God and I want to
be by myself I don't want to talk to any
of these snakes any of these people on
the internet trying to get views out of
me and these people who pretend they
support me and give a [__] when I really
at the when it gets down to the wire is
me in a jail cell me and my brother by
ourselves and all these other people
don't see [__] give a [__] until
there's views involved
lies get tired lies get exhausted it
takes Untold energy to continue to prop
up a lie it goes against the laws of
physics there's only so many times you
can tell the world I'm a human
trafficker with no evidence where's the
girls where's the videos where's the
victims where's the pictures there's
nothing how many times can you continue
to repeat the same garbage with no
evidence nobody believes it the moral
Arc of the universe bends towards truth
and I tell you something when I am
released from all of this I'm going to
use my massive platform an enormous
Financial capability to launch a charity
to prevent this happening from any man
ever again this is enough and it's gonna
have to stop and I'm gonna stop it very
powerful video
it's fun to see him like that actually
because yeah like I was saying you know
he's always doing these formal
interviews
um he's doing all these formal press
interviews as well and so we never
really get to see uh how Andrew really
feels about the situation because he's
always so calm and collected I would say
he was very calm and collected there as
well but you know I think he gave us a
little bit more overall I'm extremely
happy to see that Andrew and his brother
Tristan T are finally out of jail and
off house arrest I want to live in a
society which considers people innocent
until proven guilty anything other than
that I think is extremely dangerous and
a very Rocky Road to go down to be clear
he is of house arrest but of course he's
not allowed to leave Romania yet and
there is a trial still pending so I'm
hoping that justice will prevail and
that the truth finally wins if you
enjoyed this video found it valuable
then please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe because I have some
amazing podcast guests coming and maybe
an interview with Andrew coming soon
stay tuned